INTERVIEWER: You're
already invited.
A simple message that
could invoke excitement if
found in a Hallmark card.
But it's something that seems
much more mysterious when
taped the window of
an airplane traveling
30,000 feet in the air.
But it turns out there's a
very good reason for this note.
TAYLOR: Hi, my name
is Taylor Tippett.
I am from North Carolina.
I am a fight attendant
for a major airline,
and I'm currently
based out of DC.
INTERVIEWER: Taylor wrote
this note and decided to tape
it on the window one
day while working.
She took the quote from
one of my favorite books,
using it as a quick source
of motivation for that day.
TAYLOR: And so you're already
invited was just a pick-me-up.
Like, you're already invited
to kill this day, to nail it,
to have the best day ever.
It's already set up for you.
You just have to go do it.
So that was the encouragement
behind that specific word
from the window seat.
INTERVIEWER: Words
from the window seat
became something
Taylor did regularly.
Whenever she felt
inspired, she'd
write a quote a piece of paper
and tape it to the window.
It soon became a
hit on Instagram,
where she amassed
over 85,000 followers,
and spawned a
hashtag and copycats.
TAYLOR: If I'm not encouraging
and inspiring others,
what am I doing with my life?
What am I doing
with my time here?
I'm not doing anything.
I'm wasting it.
For my voice to matter,
and for other people
to connect, or feel loved, or
just feel understood and heard,
that is all that matters to me.
INTERVIEWER: And Taylor
also I respects her medium.
She understands it
has its boundaries
and may be best taken in via the
internet, and not as a surprise
when you take your seat.
TAYLOR: I've had some
cases, even friends of mine,
where they tape that note
up, and people freak out,
because-- they're
like, what is this?
Like, somebody left this.
This is not supposed to be here.
Once I'm done taking
my picture, I'll
tape it in the safety card
for the passenger to find it,
or for the next passenger
to find it, as a little--
just a pick-me-up.
INTERVIEWER: Taylor doesn't
do this to be famous,
or for the recognition.
She writes these notes
for the same reason she
likes being a flight attendant.
TAYLOR: There's nothing like
your office being in the sky,
and flying on a metal tube, and
meeting 300-plus people a day,
and just knowing that your
smile and your kindness matters.
INTERVIEWER: If you
love this episode
and you really want
more Seeking videos,
check out Seeker
Stories on Vessel,
where you can get
our videos three
days earlier than anywhere
else on the internet.
Click the link in
the description
feel free 30 day trial.
If you liked this episode,
don't forget to subscribe.
It's the best way to
get new Seeker Stories
episodes straight to you.
Thanks for watching.